In June 2015, I went to Sheffield, and I saw
a paternoster lift,
an obsolete design of elevator with
a looping chain of open cabs.
In June 2016, I travelled to Genoa in Italy,
and I saw an elevator that also moved sideways.
Except, spoiler, it's a bit of a cheat,
it's actually a little horizontal car
that moves inside a bigger elevator that
does the heavy lifting.
And now, it is June 2017.
And I'm in Germany, at the brand-new
Thyssenkrupp Elevator Test Tower,
and they have flown me out here
to show off Multi:
their actual, full-size, working elevator
that moves sideways without cheating.
For us, it was very important to have a tower
to test the new technology.
We don't want to test it
at the customers' site.
The tower is 246m high,
and this means 1,700 steps.
I know that exactly, because I walked up once!
This is a building made almost entirely of
elevator shafts.
Some of them test regular lifts,
but some of them are reserved
for this new system.
The principle of having
a continuous rotating flow of cars
was one of the best inventions
in our industry ever.
And to achieve this, we have to exchange cabins
from one shaft to another.
And to have this exchange, we need an exchanger,
which you see just behind me.
And this exchanger allows us
to go into horizontal movement.
The exchanger can be placed at every point
in the shaft
so it allows us to do all kinds of configurations.
Coming down vertically, and then going into
the horizontal movement.
One of the problems with elevators
in really tall buildings
is that you need a cable so long
that it can't support its own weight,
let alone the weight of the cab that's then
connected to it.
The solution here is a bit different, and
it doesn't use cables at all.
It uses linear induction motors.
Linear drive - it's also a synchronous motor
with permanent magnets.
And you maybe know it from a rotating motor.
If we just take this motor
and cut it on one side
and just lay it on a table flat,
then you already have a linear drive.
And this is what we have,
vertical and also horizontal.
In a regular elevator,
it's called a traction elevator,
you've got cables holding the cab,
any one of which can hold
more than the design weight.
Also, you've got emergency brakes
which will pop out
and slow the car down with friction
if it's moving too fast.
And, absolute worst case, even if all that
somehow fails,
you have a buffer at the bottom that should
reduce a freefall drop
from "fatal" to just "severe injuries"(!)
Elevators are incredibly safe because they're
incredibly well-regulated.
So before this is allowed to carry humans,
this system needs to be at least as failsafe.
The safety is not just in the ropes
of a conventional elevator
but in the brake system.
In conventional elevators, you have the brake
on the machine on top of the shaft in the
machine room
now we have the brake directly on the cars.
This new component, the exchanger,
where we go from vertical
into horizontal movement,
also needs to be checked by our safety controller.
What is the position of the exchanger?
Is it locked?
Is it safe?
And in case of any violation
of a safety rule,
then we go to a 'safe state'.
There are, of course, some catches.
Linear induction motors are
expensive and heavy.
Each one of the cabs
needs to have its own set.
And the whole elevator shaft,
from top to bottom,
needs to be lined with the magnetic coil units
that power them.
To save weight, these cabs are made
of carbon fibre and aluminium.
So will it work out in the real world?
Thyssenkrupp's models say it will,
but everything's been
tested and approved here,
the next step is to sell it.
To the kind of enormous multinational companies
who build skyscrapers
and who do not like risk.
And that might be a greater challenge than
making the elevators in the first place.
Thank you very much to all the team at Thyssenkrupp
who've invited me over here.
You can pull down the description
for more about Multi.